Hi everyone, and welcome to Biology
Professor. Today, we're gonna go over
how to conduct a Most Probable Number
test. So a Most Probable Number test,
or MPN is sometimes how the method
is referred to as the NPN method,
this is a method that is used to count
bacteria, to measure the amount of bacteria
in a sample. And it is ideal for estimating
the number of microbes in very dilute samples.
So when we say dilute, very dilute samples,
we mean samples where the bacteria are not
very concentrated. So we're not talking about lab
plates or lab cultures where you can do a plate
count or an optical density. These are samples
where there are much fewer bacteria present or at
least that's what you suspect. An example of this
would be various kinds of water and food testing,
so for example, testing certain kinds
of water sources for coliform bacteria.
Coliform bacteria are bacteria that can ferment
lactose and we have a lot of coliform bacteria
in human feces and so if there's coliforms in
water, that's typically indicative of fecal
contamination. So the way the MPN method works
is it uses changes in either color of broth
or changes in turbidity, that's the cloudiness
that you see when bacteria are growing in liquid
culture, so it looks for either color change
or turbidity change to detect bacterial growth.
And then you look at how many tubes either changed
color or have noted turbidity and you can count
those tubes and then interpret your results by
comparing your results to a standard reference
table. And we'll go over an example of that in
a second, but when you are using the standard
reference table, it's important that you realize
that the reference table will give you a number,
a most probable number an MPN, and then an MPN is
equal to 1 CFU. CFU is a common way of referring
to bacteria and it stands for "colony forming
unit". And basically that just means one viable
cell. So, just to recap, this method gives you
a number, a most probable number, for how many
bacteria are in a certain sample and that equates
to one colony forming unit, which is the same
thing as saying one viable cell, so one living
cell, one cell that's capable of reproducing. So
let's go through an example. First, you have your
inoculation. And so in this example, we're looking
at a water sample. Perhaps it's from a pond,
perhaps it's from a recreational swimming area,
perhaps it's a drinking water sample - we have
some water sample here and then we have three sets
of five lactose broth tubes. And remember that in
this example, we're looking for coliform bacteria
and coliform bacteria can ferment lactose. You
could do this method with other kinds of tests
where you're looking for a different kind of
color change or a different growth in turbidity
and different kinds of broth, depending on the
type bacteria you're looking at. So here we have
our three sets of five lactose brought tubes and
what we do is we take ten milliliters from the
drinking water sample and inoculate each of these
five tubes - so ten milliliters added to each one,
then we take one milliliter of the water sample
and add it to each of these tubes, and then we
take 0.1 milliliters of water from this sample and
add it to each of these tubes. And so we're having
this tenfold decrease each time in the amount
of water that's being added and so theoretically
in the amount of viable coliforms that are being
added to these tubes. Then we incubate overnight
at 37 degrees. Typically, you want to incubate
for like 24 hours for this particular method,
then it's time to read results and what that
means is you're looking for the color change.
So when coliform bacteria are present in these
broth tubes, they will ferment the lactose and
that results in a color change. And so, for this
particular test, we have four positive tubes here.
So four of them showed a color change, one did
not. We have three positive tubes here, three
showed a color change, two did not. And then where
we were adding the smallest amount of the water
sample, we've just got one positive tube, so one
changed color and four did not. And so that is our
results that we then want to come and compare in
the reference table. So our pattern, if you will,
was 4-3-1 and so we look at our reference table.
If you're a student, this is often in the back of
a textbook or in the back of like a lab manual. So
you look for the pattern of 4-3-1 and this tells
you that if you see the 4-3-1 pattern, then the
MPN, the most probable number, of coliforms in the
original sample was 33 per 100 mL. Now, if we had
gotten different patterns up here, if it had been
4-4-1 or if it had been 5-2-1 - different patterns
will result in a different most probable number,
but with this pattern of 4-3-1, the best answer
statistically is that for every 100 milliliters
of that sample we have 33 coliform bacteria.
The table also gives us a 95% confidence range,
and for the pattern 4-3-1, the 95% confidence
range is 11 to 93, so the most probable number
is 11 to 90 per 100 milliliters and all this
means is that whereas 33 is like the best guess,
the most sort of statistically supported
guess, you can be 95% confident that,
in this water sample that gave this pattern,
there is somewhere between 11 and 93 viable
coliform bacteria per 100 mL of this sample. So
that is how you conduct an MPN test. If you want
to learn more about bacterial growth, you can
check out my video on bacterial growth curves
and binary fission, but that's it for today.
Thanks for watching Biology Professor! :)